in the two weeks from the 30th of
december
uh up to the 3rd of december the uk case
rate
increased by 70
and as you can see by from these two
graphs one of which is from the middle
of december on the left
and one on the right the map is from the
30th of december
the darker colors are areas where there
are very high rates
of transmission and as you can see
across the whole of the uk
there has been a steady increase in the
rates
next slide please uh these are the most
recent
data from ons autism office for national
statistics
and what this shows is the number of
people and they do this on a
random sampling basis so this is a good
estimate of the
general population um they and this
shows the data from august
when we actually had very low rates so
in the middle of
middle of september for example one in
900 people
had rates then an increase the lock down
was brought in
and that brought down the rates but then
we had the problems of the new variant
which i'll come on to in the next slide
and the worst period of winter combining
to lead to a significant increase since
that
time and we're now into a situation
where across the country as a whole
roughly one in 50 people have got the
virus higher in some parts of the
country
lower in others but one in 50 is really
quite a
very large number indeed next slide
please
if we look around england what we find
is that
in every area there has been a
relative increase in the
new variant of this virus that is
spreading
around the country fastest increase
in the east of england london and the
southeast
but it is now taking off in other areas
as well
in some of the areas where it took off
to the highest level
and tier four was brought in during a
period when schools were closed
there may be some uh early indications
of some leveling off but i think we
shouldn't over interpret that but it is
really clear that this new variant is
has been rising
uh in all parts of the country and what
we've seen
is that the bits of the country which
have got some of the lower rates and had
previously controlled things
particularly
in the northeast and north west for
example the rate of increase
has uh in many of these been higher than
in some of the southern areas which have
got very high rates already
next slide please and this is
inevitably translated into new numbers
of patients coming into hospital
so these are the number of people in
hospital all the way from the 1st of
april
through to the 1st of january and you
can see the first peak
of people in hospital then decreased due
to the
remarkable efforts of everyone in the
country
during the first lockdown and then
through the summer months
an increase which then again went down
due to
the second lockdown but now really a
very rapid increase and i don't think
you need any modelling to see
in what direction uh the number of
hospitalized patients with kovid
is going and this is going up very
rapidly
and of course we are still in the middle
of winter
next slide please
and sadly of course some of those people
uh go on to die this is the
number of deaths of people who had a
positive test result
and there was an increase uh which led
to the second
lockdown a decrease following that
but these numbers of deaths are now
increasing again
they are at this point quite a long way
below the first peak
and there are three reasons for that the
first of which which is very good news
is that doctors nurses medical staff in
general
are able to manage this disease better
than they did previously better drugs
things like dexamethasone
but also better treatment all round
the second reason is that there is uh an
age effect that some of the people who
are being infected the moment are
younger age than in the first
wave but this obviously uh what we've
seen previously
is it moves up through the age bands
over time
but the third reason is that uh deaths
are much delayed
so what happens is people get infected
there's then a delay before they get ill
enough to go into hospital
and then there's quite a long delay
before some people sadly die
and we will unfortunately see because of
the spike
in people going into hospital from the
last slide
we will inevitably see an increase in
number of people
with who die of this disease as we go
into
the rest of january